My 1890s French carriage clock. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, Episode 194, recorded on July 11, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish our five-part conversation with Kevlin Henney and chat about the one thing every programmer should know. One final and important question for, I suppose, both of you could answer. And it's a very Bryce question, which is you, Kevlin, have written a book, 97 Things Every Programmer Should Know. But as listeners of this podcast will know i bryce don't have time for such things so can you tell me what is the one thing that every programmer
我那台1890年代的法国马车钟。欢迎收听ADSP播客第194期，录制于2024年7月11日。我是Connor，今天我和联合主持人Bryce一起，结束我们与Kevlin Henney的五部分系列访谈，并聊聊每个程序员都应该知道的一件事。我想，最后有一个重要的问题，你们两位都可以回答。这是一个非常“Bryce式”的问题，那就是：Kevlin，你写过一本书叫《每个程序员都应该知道的97件事》。但正如本播客的听众所知，我Bryce没有时间看这些书，所以你能告诉我，每个程序员都应该知道的那一件事是什么吗？
ah right so i took a minor correction i didn't write it i edited it i ran the product i kind of got everybody i contributed a few items that i wrote but therefore it is a crowdsourced and open source book. So yes, it actually is under creative commons license. That was intentional on my part. So you can actually find a few versions kicking around online every now and then I get, yeah, you're not allowed to have the PDF of the book, but the original entries were originally available on a wiki. And so I've had people, people have scraped this and put this into Git books and GitHub in various places. So you don't have to buy the book. You can find the items online if you wish. And that's perfectly okay. The reason I'm saying it's perfectly okay is because occasionally I get an email from somebody saying, hey, guess what? Did you know
啊，对了，我得做一个小小的更正，我不是作者，我是编辑。我负责这个项目，我把大家召集起来，我自己也贡献了几篇文章，但它本质上是一本众包和开源的书。所以是的，它实际上是在知识共享许可协议下发布的。这是我刻意为之的。所以你偶尔可以在网上找到几个版本，虽然我常听到有人说：“嘿，你不被允许拥有这本书的PDF”，但原始条目最初是在一个维基页面上发布的。所以有人抓取了这些内容，并把它们放到了GitBook和GitHub的各个地方。所以你不必买书，如果你愿意，可以在网上找到这些条目。这完全没问题。我之所以说完全没问题，是因为偶尔会有人给我发邮件说：“嘿，你猜怎么着？你知道吗……”
somebody's ripped off your book? And no, it's intentional. Creative comms license, that's absolutely fine. They can't rip off the PDF. That's kind of differently copyrighted. But the individual items, absolutely. They're under creative commons. Now, why am I telling you all of this, Bob? That so that we don't inspire more emails to me that aren't necessary,
“有人盗版了你的书？”不，这是故意的。知识共享许可协议，这完全没问题。他们不能盗版PDF，那是有不同版权的。但单个条目，绝对没问题。它们是在知识共享协议下的。好了，Bob，我为什么要告诉你这些？是为了让我们不再收到更多不必要的邮件，
but also to allow people to do this if they don't want to part dollars. But more importantly, there are lots of contributors to that book. So I've got an opt-out of this question that you've just asked because I'm not going to pick favorites. There are 73 contributors to that book. I'm not going to pick one because that's unfair on the other 72. So I've got a get-out clause here that Connor doesn't have.
但也是为了让那些不想花钱的人也能看到。更重要的是，那本书有很多贡献者。所以我对你刚才问的这个问题有一个“免责条款”，因为我不会偏袒任何人。那本书有73位贡献者。我不会挑选其中一个，因为这对其他72个人不公平。所以我这里有一个Connor没有的“脱身条款”。
Ah. Ah. Yes. So Connor, what is the one thing that every programmer should know? I mean, I just went and found the git thing because I'm trying to find the one of the five because I'm pretty sure that one of the things in the 97 things is it quotes i'm not going to remember the name of the book because the original quote comes from another
啊。啊。是的。那么Connor，每个程序员都应该知道的那一件事是什么？我是说，我刚才去查了那个Git的东西，因为我正试图从那五件事里找出一个，因为我很确定《97件事》里的其中一件事引用了……我不记得书名了，因为原始引文来自另一本
book and i've mentioned this in talks before but basically like i think potentially it's learn foreign languages yes but i've gone to that there's languages that one if i remember um correctly is klaus markfart there is another one no more than one language well if i remember correctly um more no more than two no well more than two programming languages um that was russell winder so but wait wait kevin so i may have to revoke you out. And the reason is these things are numbered, which means that somebody had to pick which one was going to be number one. Ah, right. They are, strictly speaking, the original book, they are not numbered.
书，我以前在演讲中提到过，但基本上，我认为可能是“学习外语”。是的，但我查过了，有关于语言的那一条，如果我没记错的话，嗯，是Klaus Markfart写的；还有另一条，关于“掌握不止一种语言”的，嗯，如果我没记错的话，是Russell Winder写的。等等，等等，Kevlin，我可能得反驳你。原因在于这些条目是有编号的，这意味着有人必须选出哪一个是第一条。啊，对了。严格来说，原书中它们是没有编号的。
They are numbered in the electronic copies. Ah. But if you look at the titles, you will understand how I ordered it. Is it alphabetical? It is alphabetical. Ah. But if you look at the titles, you will understand how I ordered it. Is it alphabetical? It is alphabetical. Ah. Because I thought I can't play favorites. But also, if you try and group things by topic.
它们在电子版中是有编号的。啊。但如果你看标题，你就会明白我是如何排序的。是按字母顺序吗？是的，是按字母顺序。啊。因为我想我不能偏袒谁。而且，如果你试图按主题对它们进行分组……
It's very hard to group things. Yeah. You often find one, you find a piece and it's actually under two good. You can file it under equally well under two different... Categorizing stuff... As somebody who's in the role of being a software architect, taking ideas and concepts and
很难对事物进行分组。是的。你经常会发现一篇文章，它其实可以归入两个类别。你可以同样好地把它归入两个不同的……分类……作为一个软件架构师，获取想法和概念并
categorizing them is like one of the... It's like a big part of the job and it's also one of the hardest things. Exactly, yeah. And I chose... So it's interesting how other 97 Things books in that series have chosen to do it. The original 97 Things Every Software Architect Should Know had the most arbitrary order. So I was originally part of the group.
对它们进行分类是……这是工作的一大部分，也是最难的事情之一。没错，确实。所以我选择了……所以很有趣的是，该系列中的其他《97件事》书籍是如何选择处理这个问题的。最初的《每个软件架构师都应该知道的97件事》采用了最随意的排序方式。所以我最初是该小组的一员。
I could kind of make sense of it. But when it was published, it was the order in which they were submitted. Now, that is utterly meaningless to anybody reading the book. I mean, you don't know what order they were submitted. Why is that useful so it meant that sometimes you know that you'd end up with topics that you could you'd say well why is this person has submitted two items why are they next to each other and then this other person who submitted two items their items are like 50 pages apart well that's literally the timeline um there was another i guess one could argue that the people who had their shit the most together probably submitted early. And so at the very least, those were the ones that had the most urgency and the people who were best at getting it done on a deadline. So that's not a terrible mechanism. That's a very positive way of framing it. On the other hand, maybe they just got something done and they didn't let something gestate and mature over time.
我还能理解一点。但当它出版时，它是按提交的顺序排列的。这对任何读这本书的人来说都毫无意义。我是说，你不知道它们提交的顺序。为什么这有用呢？这意味着有时你会发现，你可能会问：“为什么这个人提交了两篇文章，它们却排在一起？而另一个人提交了两篇文章，它们却相隔50页？”嗯，那字面上就是时间线。还有人可能会争辩说，那些准备得最充分的人可能提交得最早。所以至少，那些是最紧迫的，也是最擅长在截止日期前完成任务的人。所以这并不是一个糟糕的机制。这是一种非常积极的解读方式。另一方面，也许他们只是完成了任务，而没有让想法随着时间沉淀和成熟。
So maybe the ones at the back of the book are better because people were more deliberate about them and they'd let the ideas sit with them for longer. Yeah, I mean, both of these lines of argument work. I do like the first one, which is Act with Prudence. Yeah, by Severus. I think that's a good one, I think. Yeah. It's kind of interesting is that alphabetically that one, you know, that's obviously first, but also actually it's quite a good opening to the book.
所以也许书后面的那些更好，因为人们对它们更深思熟虑，让想法在脑海中停留了更长时间。是的，我是说，这两种论点都成立。我确实喜欢第一条，即“谨慎行事”（Act with Prudence）。是的，Severus写的。我觉得那是一条很好的建议。是的。有趣的是，按字母顺序排列，那条显然排在第一位，但实际上它也是这本书非常好的开篇。
Yeah, it is. I was delighted by the coincidence because obviously reverse order was also an option. But I decided up front there's no rational way of organizing 97 things when you don't delighted by the coincidence because obviously reverse order was also an option but i decided up front there's no rational way of organizing 97 things when you don't know what 97 things you're going to get i tried putting categories on them but i already knew it was a it's a library problem in the sense of like there's no natural structure here if i'm creating a book from scratch and i solicit individual items explicitly i can say we want, this, this is my vision for the book. But this is very much an emergent architecture
是的，确实。我对这个巧合感到很高兴，因为显然反向排序也是一种选择。但我事先决定，当你不知道会得到哪97件事时，没有理性的方式来组织它们。我试过给它们分类，但我已经知道这是一个“图书馆问题”，意思是这里没有自然的结构。如果我是从零开始创作一本书，并且明确征集单个条目，我可以说明：“我们想要这个，这是我对这本书的愿景。”但这是一次非常“涌现式”的架构，
where I got, you know, I got nearly 200 submissions. It was around 100, it was around towards 170. And what you've got to do is kind of say, here's what I've got, what can I make with it? You know, it's, you know, it's go to the fridge and I don't know what happened with your fridge there, Bryce, but, you know, I don't know what the narrative is with the know it's it's go to the fridge and i don't know what happened with your fridge there bryce but you know i don't know what the narrative is with the fridge but it's go to your fridge and i go to the fridge i'm hungry go to the fridge i need to make a meal what have i got so you in other words something emerges from that without necessarily saying i am planning
我收到了近200份投稿。大约是170份左右。你必须做的是说：“这就是我所拥有的，我能用它做出什么？”你知道，这就像去冰箱找吃的，我不知道你的冰箱发生了什么，Bryce，但我不知道关于冰箱的叙述是什么，但就是去你的冰箱，我饿了，去冰箱，我需要做顿饭，我有什么？所以换句话说，某种东西从中涌现出来，而不必说“我计划
to make this meal so i chose alphabet and i did that in the other 97 things book as well it's the alphabetical is the only rational way to allow people to find things all other approaches are arbitrary let me tell you the other arbitrary approach that was used uh one of the other arbitrary approaches that was used was for 97 things every project manager should know that was interesting because i was looking at it going like i can't see any sense to the ordering of these the editor of that book decided that the ordering of the book should alternate u.s contributors from non-u.s contributors or u.s based contributors from non-u.s based contributors honestly that's almost as good as random number generation i think that's a good that's a good approach because it accounts for some of the um bias of a lot of tech is very
要做这顿饭”。所以我选择了字母顺序，我在另一本《97件事》书中也这样做过。按字母顺序是允许人们找到东西的唯一理性方式，所有其他方法都是随意的。让我告诉你另一种被使用的随意方法，呃，其中一种被使用的方法是针对《每个项目经理都应该知道的97件事》。那很有趣，因为我看着它心想：“我看不出这些排序有什么意义。”那本书的编辑决定，书的排序应该交替使用美国贡献者和非美国贡献者，或者美国本土贡献者和非美国本土贡献者。老实说，这几乎和随机数生成一样好。我认为这是一种不错的方法，因为它解释了一些关于……很多技术非常
US centric and based in the US. But the point is that if half your items are US and half them are not, there isn't actually, I would say there isn't a, why? Yeah. If I read the first one, US author, second one, non-US author, that's not a useful criteria for finding that item again. Yes. Yes know I would I would agree yeah so the question of representation is certainly an important one and is definitely something I dealt with I tried dealing with it with moderate success on the first book but not
以美国为中心，且总部位于美国。但重点是，如果一半条目是美国的，一半不是，实际上并没有……我会说没有一个……为什么？是的。如果我读第一条是美国作者，第二条是非美国作者，那不是再次找到该条目的有用标准。是的，是的，我知道，我会同意的。所以代表性的问题当然是一个重要的问题，也绝对是我处理过的问题。我在第一本书上尝试处理它，取得了一定的成功，但没有
as much as we managed on the second one but it's the idea of like this is how we're going to order the items it's just like that's not useful i don't know if this author is us or not um and you know i can't tell um you know you know that's not helpful to me i can't so i i structured it um and i intentionally put in a reverse look up as well at the back of the book. So you might remember, oh, I remember the thing was written by so-and-so, you know, by this person. Let me – I can remember the name, but I can't remember the title. So I did it alphabetical by name. Are any anonymous or under pseudonyms?
我们在第二本书上做得那么多。但这是一种“这就是我们要如何排序条目”的想法，这只是……那没用。我不知道这位作者是否是美国的，而且你知道，我看不出来……你知道，那对我没帮助。所以我……我构建了它，并且我特意在书的后面放了一个反向索引。所以你可能记得：“哦，我记得那件事是某某写的。”你知道，是这个人写的。让我……我记得名字，但我记不住标题。所以我按名字的字母顺序做了索引。有匿名的或使用笔名的吗？
There's one that is a pseudonym. Okay. Yeah. And how did you pick, why 97? This is a good question. It wasn't me that originally picked it. As I mentioned, it emerged, it got created out of a separate discussion, a separate list. It's a list that bruce eckel maintains so uh some listeners may may be faintly aware of bruce eckel he wrote thinking in c++ and he actually made that the that book freely available um so decades ago very very influential approach to making um the stuff
有一个是笔名。好的。那你怎么选的，为什么是97？这是一个好问题。最初选这个数字的不是我。正如我提到的，它是涌现出来的，它是从一个单独的讨论、一个单独的列表中创建出来的。这是Bruce Eckel维护的一个列表，所以呃，一些听众可能隐约知道Bruce Eckel，他写了《Thinking in C++》，他实际上让那本书免费可用……所以几十年前，这是一种非常有影响力的让……东西
available but also quite a deep and thorough book at the time um for anybody who was trying to get into c++ uh And this is on Bruce Eccles' list. And a guy called Richard Monson-Hayford, he originally wanted to, he said, I've submitted a talk. I think it was 10 things every software architect should know. I've submitted a talk to a conference. Now I've got the title and they've accepted the talk. I need 10 things. What do you guys think? So everybody started chipping in these ideas. And after about 30 suggestions, he said, you know what, there might be something here for a book. And that was the order. But then he said, okay, how many should we have? And he said, I 100 is a slightly cheesy number. And he says, 99 and 101 are numbers that are trying too hard to not be 100. They're too obvious. And he said, 97, it doesn't look like it's trying to be 100, but it's its own thing. And that really is it. That is the only reason for it.
可用的方法，而且在当时也是一本非常深刻和详尽的书……对于任何试图进入C++领域的人来说。这是在Bruce Eckel的列表上。一个叫Richard Monson-Haefel的人，他最初想……他说：“我提交了一个演讲，我想是《每个软件架构师都应该知道的10件事》。我向会议提交了一个演讲。现在我有标题了，他们也接受了演讲。我需要10件事。你们觉得呢？”所以每个人都开始贡献这些想法。在大约30个建议之后，他说：“你知道吗，这里可能有一本书的内容。”这就是顺序。但后来他说：“好吧，我们应该有多少条？”他说：“100是一个稍微有点俗气的数字。”他说：“99和101是那些试图努力不成为100的数字。它们太明显了。”他说：“97，它看起来不像是在努力成为100，但它有自己的特色。”这就是原因。这就是唯一的原因。
Good for SEO, right? If you search like like like i'm sure there's a bazillion listicles of 99 things programmers should know or 100 things or 101 things but 97 that that's yeah it's for those that care it's a strong prime although you'd never use it in cryptography but it is 97 it's a strong prime but it is it is distinct you know it's seo friendly um the reason 100 works is he wanted about two pages. So 200 page book, that's actually quite nice. It doesn't give you depth on each item. But one of the things I really liked about it
对SEO有好处，对吧？如果你搜索……就像我肯定有无数关于“程序员应该知道的99件事”或“100件事”或“101件事”的列表文章，但97……那确实……是的，对于那些在乎的人来说，这是一个强素数，尽管你永远不会在密码学中使用它，但它确实是97，它是一个强素数，但它确实是独特的。你知道，它对SEO友好。100之所以有效，是因为他想要大约两页纸。所以200页的书，这其实很不错。它没有给你每个条目的深度。但我真正喜欢它的一点是
and why I ended up really pushing the program book was I thought this is really useful because it's helpful to start conversations. It's the starting point. You read something, you can read it in a break. You can read it in a break you can look at it and go hmm i want to know more or this has already influenced the way i'm thinking oh i see what they're saying and it's just enough to get you going sometimes it's enough to just change the way that you approach the problem or to present something new to that you perhaps hadn't considered before but it's not a whole you know you're not committing
我最终真正推动那本程序员书的原因是，我认为这非常有用，因为它有助于开启对话。这是一个起点。你读了一些东西，你可以在休息时读它。你可以在休息时看它，然后心想：“嗯，我想知道更多”或者“这已经影响了我的思考方式”。“哦，我明白他们想说什么了。”它足以让你开始。有时，仅仅改变你处理问题的方式，或者向你展示一些你以前可能没考虑过的新东西就足够了。但它不是一个完整的……你知道，你不需要投入
um you know an hour or a day of your time to it but it'll it gives you just, but it's not a whole, you know, you're not committing, you know, an hour or a day of your time to it, but it gives you just enough. But it's also quite good for book bombing. And I know a couple of people who did that. It's just like, send this to a friend, send it to a friend and make sure you put a post-it on the page that you wanted them to see, you know. So the physical form of book bombing is quite useful. A subtle hint, sometimes when you have a a disagreement with a colleague about um a particular practice yeah just leave that book on there uh on their on their table with a little post-it there so i mean i'm not you know the weaponization of 97 things has been interesting but uh but yeah uh so that that that was that and that's the the
嗯，你知道，一小时或一天的时间，但它给了你足够的启发。而且它也非常适合“书本轰炸”（book bombing）。我知道有几个人这样做过。就是把它寄给朋友，寄给朋友，并确保在你想让他们看到的页面上贴一张便利贴，你知道。所以书本轰炸的物理形式非常有用。一个微妙的暗示，有时当你和同事对……某种特定做法有分歧时，是的，就把那本书放在他们的桌子上，贴上一张小便利贴。所以我的意思是，我不是……你知道，97件事的武器化一直很有趣，但……但是的，所以这就是那个，这就是
rationale for a lot of these things so so you i mean i i'm very impressed here because i always like to work smart and not uh hard and you've been able to write a book without having to write 97 things yourself by being a curator of things and that is that is uh that is very very commendable that's yeah that's uh i i think i think there is that there is an interesting thing because i actually really enjoyed the whole process of doing the editing because it allowed but actually the other motivation and why i was happy to do it was really into doing another book so i actually really enjoyed it was when you read across what other people do although sometimes you say yeah i know that i don't know it the way you know it i don't know the way that person knows
很多这些事情的理由。所以你……我的意思是，我印象非常深刻，因为我总是喜欢聪明地工作，而不是……努力地工作。你能够写一本书，而不必自己写97件事，而是通过成为事物的策展人，这是……这是非常值得称赞的。那是……是的，我想……我想有一件有趣的事情，因为我实际上非常享受整个编辑过程，因为它允许……但实际上另一个动机，以及为什么我很高兴去做它，是因为我真的想做另一本书。所以我实际上非常享受它，当你阅读其他人所做的事情时，虽然有时你会说：“是的，我知道那个，但我不知道你所知道的那种方式。”我不知道那个人知道的方式，
it and i wouldn't have written it like that and And the way they've written it is fresh. If you read across the 97 things, and Connor has, you look at some of them, they're real gems. And the point is, they're not the variety of style and the differences of approaches. You go, oh, okay, that's really interesting. You're not going to get bored. A single author has control over the narrative. Okay. There's value in that. You want want that consistency but when you're trying to take on you know something as complex software development you probably want to do this by sampling you know i want different points of view i want uh i want to be surprised by stuff and i was surprised by both books and in fact by some of the other books where i'm looking at it
而且我不会那样写。他们写的方式很新鲜。如果你通读这97件事，Connor也读过，你看其中的一些，它们真的是瑰宝。重点是，它们不是……风格的多样性和方法的差异。你会说：“哦，好吧，那真的很有趣。”你不会感到无聊。单一作者对叙事有控制权。好吧，那有价值。你想要那种一致性，但当你试图处理……你知道，像软件开发这样复杂的事情时，你可能想通过抽样来做到这一点。你知道，我想要不同的观点，我想要……我想要被事物所惊喜。我被这两本书所惊喜，事实上，也被其他一些书所惊喜，我看着它们
going like i kind of knew that but i didn't know it the way they do it and i wouldn't't have said it that way, but I like the way they say it. That's fresh. It makes me think of different things. And that I think is quite valuable. But yeah, you're right. Ultimately. How much did you have to edit to get to like a consistent language or to get to consistent, like, is it very lightly edited or is it more like you had to draft things a little bit and reshape things a bit i uh it depended it depended on the it depended on the contribution i mean sometimes and actually that was another thing i explicitly although i don't know if this was richard monson haefel's original intention but i explicitly made a point when i was um you know when people would contact me i'd sort of talk about this at conferences and say you know let me know if you're interested in
心想：“我有点知道那个，但我不知道他们所知道的方式，我不会那样说，但我喜欢他们说的方式。”那很新鲜。它让我想到了不同的事情。我认为这非常有价值。但是的，你是对的。最终，你必须编辑多少才能达到一种一致的语言，或者达到一致的……它是被轻微编辑的，还是更像是你必须起草一些东西并稍微重塑一下？我……这取决于……这取决于贡献。我的意思是，有时……事实上，这是另一件事，虽然我不知道这是否是Richard Monson-Haefel最初的意图，但我明确地在……你知道，当人们联系我时，我会……我在会议上谈论这个，并说：“你知道，如果你有兴趣，请告诉我。”
contributing i mean i contacted a few people saying hey would you be interested in contributing but actually a lot actually came uh from people i don't know um uh just because i advertised it on twitter at the time and stuff like that and i made a real point about saying on the landing page it was done through a wiki i made a point on the landing page, it was done through a wiki. I made a point on the landing page. It's just like, if you're not comfortable with writing, perhaps English isn't your first language, don't worry. You're talking about 500 pages. I can do the editing. If you're worried about language, I want your enthusiasm and your knowledge.
贡献。我的意思是，我联系了几个人说：“嘿，你有兴趣贡献吗？”但实际上很多确实来自……我不知道的人，呃，只是因为我当时在Twitter上做了广告之类的。我确实强调了在登录页面上，它是通过维基完成的。我强调了在登录页面上，它是通过维基完成的。我强调了在登录页面上。这就像：“如果你不擅长写作，也许英语不是你的第一语言，别担心。你在谈论500页。我可以做编辑。如果你担心语言，我想要你的热情和知识。”
Give me the story and I can shape it. So sometimes I'm getting stuff and I'm having to do a lot of syntactic level work or phrasing and voice stuff. And I always did that one-to-one via email, obviously, but one-to-one with the author. And I put a lot of effort in. So I would say there was a lot of effort involved in the writing because I wanted to have a proper consent
给我故事，我可以塑造它。所以有时我得到一些东西，我必须做很多句法层面的工作，或者措辞和语气方面的工作。我总是通过电子邮件一对一地做，显然，但与作者一对一地做。我投入了很多精力。所以我可以说，写作中投入了大量的精力，因为我想有一个适当的同意
and agreement and to give, you know, just say, is this okay with you? And so on. Whereas for other people, there's a couple in there, I didn't even move a comma. It's just like, it's just like, I don't want to touch this. This is so good as it is, or actually that captures their voice perfectly. So it varied. But overall, the whole set is I edited all the items before I selected. So I edited nearly 200 items as they came in. And so I'd be doing something. That's how many submissions you got? Yeah, it's 170 submissions, around 170.
和协议，并给予……你知道，只是说：“这对你来说可以吗？”等等。而对于其他人，里面有几篇，我甚至没有动过一个逗号。这就像……这就像：“我不想碰这个。它本身就这么好，或者实际上这完美地捕捉了他们的声音。”所以情况各不相同。但总的来说，整个集合是……我在选择之前编辑了所有的条目。所以我编辑了近200个条目。这就是你收到的投稿数量？是的，170份投稿，大约170份。
And so I was editing everything pretty much as it came in. I created a proper workflow for myself. And so there was a continuous amount, you know, in a given week or on a given day. I would always be devoting a certain amount of time to it. And so there was certainly an effort there. But I found that but ultimately I found that easier than than writing. I mean, I've written a couple of books myself and it's just like, I don't know, it's it works differently for different people. But all I will say is that my wife told me after 97 things, she said,
所以我几乎在收到每一件东西时都在编辑。我为自己创建了一个适当的工作流程。所以有一个持续的数量，你知道，在特定的一周或特定的一天。我总是会投入一定的时间。所以那里肯定有努力。但我发现……但最终我发现这比写作更容易。我的意思是，我自己写过几本书，这就像……我不知道，它对不同的人有不同的作用。但我只想说，我妻子在《97件事》之后告诉我，她说：
Kevin, you're a lot more pleasant when you're editing a book than when you're writing one. As a human being to live with, okay, I get that. So, yeah, I can see that it's funny because despite my despite my my joke earlier um i actually can imagine that uh having to be an editor for 97 different was it 97 unique individuals that submitted no 73 unique individuals okay yeah having to be having. Having to interact with and work with 73 different people, some of whom you had to go back and forth with edits on and you had to make sure you got everybody's sign off and everything. Most of whom I don't know. So that's the other thing. This actually sounds like a good bit of work, a different type of work. I guess maybe the nice thing
“Kevlin，你在编辑一本书时比在写一本书时要讨人喜欢得多。”作为一个一起生活的人，好吧，我明白了。所以，是的，我可以看出这很有趣，因为尽管我之前开了个玩笑，呃，我实际上可以想象，呃，必须成为97个不同……是97个独特个体提交的吗？不，73个独特个体。好的，是的，必须成为……必须与73个不同的人互动和工作，其中一些人你必须来回修改，你必须确保你得到了每个人的签字等等。其中大多数人我不认识。所以这是另一回事。这听起来确实是一项不错的工作，一种不同类型的工作。我想也许不错的事情
about this versus writing a book on your own is if you're writing a book on your own, you have to push the work out. Whereas if you're an editor in this sense, you have all this stuff coming in. You have to keep up with it, but you don't end up in that writer's block mode. Yeah's block mode yeah i i mean although i guess i'm listed as the editor i would call myself the the project driver because it was kind of like i really kind of pushed this one
关于这个与自己写书相比，如果你自己写书，你必须推动工作。而如果你是这种意义上的编辑，你有所有这些东西进来。你必须跟上它，但你不会陷入那种“写作障碍”模式。是的，写作障碍模式。是的，我……我的意思是，虽然我想我被列为编辑，但我会称自己为“项目驱动者”，因为这有点像我真的推动了这个项目，
because i've noticed that a couple of the other editors in the series they're very very passive in other words they say i'm going to be the editor and then they expect the publisher to go out and do this and i said no no this is my baby i'm gonna i want you know this is going to be the editor and then they expect the publisher to go out and do this. And I said, no, no, no, this is my baby. I'm going to I want you know, this is going to be social media, the whole thing. I'm interested. I'm genuinely interested in what people have to offer here. So I'm going to drive this project. And it is, you know, as you say, it's got a different enjoyment, but it's got a steady state to it. And that's what I appreciated.
因为我注意到该系列中的其他几位编辑，他们非常非常被动。换句话说，他们说：“我要成为编辑”，然后他们期望出版商出去做这件事。我说：“不，不，不，这是我的孩子。我要……我想要你知道，这将会是……”他们期望出版商出去做这件事。我说：“不，不，不，这是我的孩子。我要……我想要你知道，这将会是社交媒体，整个事情。”我很感兴趣。我真心对人们在这里提供的东西感兴趣。所以我打算推动这个项目。而且它是，你知道，正如你所说，它有不同的乐趣，但它有一种稳定的状态。这就是我所欣赏的。
But I think there's also an irony. After I finished, I co-authored two pattern books with Frank Bushman and Doug Schmidt. And Frank Bushman made the point, and I suddenly realized all the stuff I've done is contributing to other people's books or stuff like that in the past or co-authoring. And he told me, Kevlin, having worked with you, I don't think you're ever going to write a book on your own because I used to write columns and a column has a deadline. If you're writing for a magazine or a website, you have a deadline and I can work to a deadline. So this is ADHD brain. Okay. I can work to a deadline. You give me a deadline and it's meaningful. Oh, I can do that. If you've got something really abstract and there's a whole book, I find that very difficult. And if I'm working with other authors, actually, that's a collaboration. It's like, this is all like developing software. You know, this is all feels like you're working with colleagues and they're driving you, you're driving them, hopefully not mad, but you know,
但我认为还有一个讽刺之处。在我完成后，我和Frank Buschmann以及Doug Schmidt合著了两本模式书。Frank Buschmann指出了这一点，我突然意识到我过去所做的一切都是为别人的书做贡献，或者类似的事情，或者合著。他告诉我：“Kevlin，和你一起工作过，我不认为你会自己写一本书。”因为我过去写专栏，而专栏有截止日期。如果你为杂志或网站写作，你有截止日期，我可以按照截止日期工作。所以这是ADHD大脑。好的。我可以按照截止日期工作。你给我一个截止日期，它是有意义的。哦，我可以做到。如果你有一些非常抽象的东西，而且是一整本书，我发现这非常困难。如果我和其他作者一起工作，实际上，那是一种合作。这就像……这就像开发软件。你知道，这感觉就像你和同事一起工作，他们在推动你，你在推动他们，希望不会让他们发疯，但你知道，
there's all of this. So that was the funny thing. Frank said, I don't think you're going to write a book on your own. So what did I do? i went out and found 73 people and uh or rather ultimately it was 100 people who contributed so ultimately i proved frank right by going the opposite end rather than having a book of one i had a i had 100 uh contributors all told so the opposite end of the scale oh yeah right so uh the other books you've written was uh it's the two pattern oriented ones right yeah yeah those are the ones that my name appears is that i've edited a couple of other things and contributed to a couple of other things where i'm not necessarily directly credited why didn't o'reilly want to do uh 97 things that every c++ programmer should know
有所有这些。所以这就是有趣的事情。Frank说：“我不认为你会自己写一本书。”所以我做了什么？我出去找了73个人，呃，或者更确切地说，最终有100个人做出了贡献。所以最终我通过走相反的极端证明了Frank是对的，而不是拥有一本一个人的书，我有了……我有100个贡献者。所以规模的另一端。哦，是的，对了。所以，呃，你写的其他书是……是那两本面向模式的书，对吧？是的，是的，那些是我的名字出现的书。我编辑过其他几样东西，并为其他几样东西做出了贡献，我并不一定直接被署名。为什么O'Reilly不想做《每个C++程序员都应该知道的97件事》？
i don't know yeah yeah that was uh peter somerland approached them um so i don't know. Yeah, yeah. That was Peter Sommelad approached them. So I don't know the conversation he had. I think he did that around 2020, 2021. Oh, yeah. You know what? I recall him. I think he emailed me about that. Yeah, yeah.
我不知道。是的，是的，那是……Peter Sommelad联系了他们，所以我不知道。是的，是的，那是Peter Sommelad联系了他们。所以我不知道他进行的对话。我想他在2020年、2021年左右做了这件事。哦，是的。你知道吗？我记得他。我想他给我发过关于那个的电子邮件。是的，是的。
I think it would be, I think it's a mistake not to do that because you've got an active language community you can look at any programming language um uh you know top 10 um and uh yeah yeah connor knows this you'll get into it and you'll see c++ isn't there you know it's a point is that this is this has a large pool not simply of contributors but people who would be interested um and it kind of ties back to what we were talking about, normalizing culture, voices. We have a lot of good C++. We have a lot of good people individually who are good at this, who have individually produced good books and good resources online. We tend to associate that with them. We're also very familiar with the idea of open source development in the software. The point is that a project like this brings the two together. It gives you a cross section.
我认为这会是……我认为不这样做是一个错误，因为你有一个活跃的语言社区。你可以看任何编程语言，呃，你知道，前10名，而且……是的，是的，Connor知道这一点，你会进入它，你会看到C++不在那里。你知道，重点是，这有一个庞大的群体，不仅仅是贡献者，还有那些会感兴趣的人。而且它有点回到了我们正在谈论的内容，规范文化、声音。我们有很多好的C++。我们有很多好的个人，他们擅长这个，他们个人制作了好的书和好的在线资源。我们倾向于将那与他们联系起来。我们也对软件中的开源开发理念非常熟悉。重点是，像这样的项目将两者结合在一起。它给了你一个横截面。
It gives you a variety of thoughts. And importantly, I think that's important because not everybody's going to agree with each other. I actually had a couple of emails in the past where people have emailed me and said, Kevin, you're the editor. How did you put together two pieces here that contradict each other? And I said, well, that's for you to figure out. I'm saying I don't have the answer or rather, I might believe I have the answer, but I'm respecting your intelligence and the fact that
它给了你各种各样的想法。而且重要的是，我认为这很重要，因为不是每个人都会同意彼此。我过去实际上收到过几封电子邮件，人们给我发邮件说：“Kevlin，你是编辑。你怎么把这里两篇相互矛盾的文章放在一起？”我说：“嗯，那是你自己去弄清楚的。”我说我没有答案，或者更确切地说，我可能相信我有答案，但我尊重你的智慧，以及这样一个事实：
there are two points of view on this and I'm going to show you both. And I want to present where there is contention or diversity on this view. You should be the person who makes the choice. I'm going to present you with both of those. It's not a done deal. There isn't the one true way. These are not the 97 things in one unified, mandated way. These are a selection that happens to be 97 from a variety of people who overlap, but in some cases contradict. And we leave it to the reader to do that.
关于这一点有两种观点，我将向你展示两者。我想展示存在争议或多样性的地方。你应该成为做出选择的人。我将向你展示这两者。这不是板上钉钉的。没有唯一的真理。这些不是以一种统一的、强制的方式呈现的97件事。这些是一个选择，恰好是97个，来自各种各样的人，他们有重叠，但在某些情况下是矛盾的。我们留给读者去处理。
And I think in the C++ space, that's also important. Imagine having 97 practices that are from top level to low level, that are across your tool chain into the detail of the language, that are about how you relate to your colleagues, as well as how you relate to your code, that talk about legacy, but also talk about new code, that talk about testing, but talk about pill pipeline, a book that really just samples the whole space 97 things and a whole lot of different people contributing i think that'd be really interesting because you're then getting a sense of oh this is the c++ world and i think that is true for pretty much any language and it is a value there so i think you know i yeah i find there's value in the project, but I'm not a publisher. Well, I think it sounds like it would have been a good book.
而且我认为在C++领域，这也很重要。想象一下拥有97种实践，从顶层到底层，跨越你的工具链到语言的细节，关于你如何与同事相处，以及你如何与代码相处，谈论遗留代码，但也谈论新代码，谈论测试，但谈论管道，一本真正采样整个空间的97件事的书，以及很多不同的人贡献，我认为那会非常有趣，因为你随后会有一种感觉：“哦，这就是C++世界。”我认为这对于几乎任何语言都是如此，而且那里有价值。所以我认为你知道，我……我发现这个项目有价值，但我不是出版商。嗯，我认为听起来那会是一本好书。
I like the C++ books that I do like that I've talked about on this podcast before, ones that are a collection of, you know, like the beautiful code or the effective C++, where it's like I don't have to read through a whole thing. It's like a list of little snippets that I can consume. You can dip in, you get a point of view you learn you walk away having thought about something um and you know i think that that's i think that's the real value but also the fact that you you're not just getting one voice i think that's really important all right well we probably ought to uh wrap up because my uh my 1890s french carriage clock
我喜欢我在这本播客中提到过的我喜欢的C++书籍，那些是……的集合，你知道，像《Beautiful Code》或《Effective C++》，它就像我不需要通读整本书。它就像我可以消费的小片段列表。你可以深入了解，你得到一个观点，你学习，你离开时思考了一些事情。而且你知道，我认为……我认为这是真正的价值。但还有这样一个事实，你……你不仅仅是在得到一个声音，我认为这真的很重要。好吧，好吧，我们可能应该……结束了，因为我的……我的1890年代法国马车钟
the ac slash fridge tobaccos. Oh, uh-oh. It looks like it's, uh, maybe I'm losing internet now. It does look that. Yeah, it's actually a great screen. Your screen is frozen. It's fantastic. It's like you're having a 90s
AC/冰箱烟草。哦，呃哦。看起来它……呃，也许我现在正在失去互联网。看起来确实是这样。是的，这实际上是一个很棒的屏幕。你的屏幕冻结了。这太棒了。就像你正在经历一个90年代
rave moment. Anyways, that may be a sign that it's time for us to wrap up. The universe is speaking. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSPThePodcast.com for us to wrap up. The universe is speaking. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts,
狂欢时刻。无论如何，这可能是一个我们该结束的信号。宇宙正在说话。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在ADSPThePodcast.com上，以获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、
comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。